[Music]  it was about a 15 he'll obey if you're  nervous about it why are you doing it  because Ella needs to make sure that  she's got formula and Joshua ain't damn  providing for okay so we're gonna start  with some of the looks in the black  these are super cute so if you can want  to start with that you wanna help her  out okay I'm baby I'm so glad you're  here to help me but I ain't beard up you  and I'm sure and figured out putting him  on but don't think I'm bitter he taking  him off oh don't you buck her down there  look scruffy going on she did we got a  treatment yes sir  she's got a machete Arizona  are you sure you can do this used to be  landscaping with residential commercial  commercial not that damn thing he's not  that damn to anything  baby careful girl you be careful it's  about even on top June are you ready to  go my god alright appreciate maybe five  minutes okay dang it Phil my name wrong